hey what is happening here welcome to
the latest update
on the buy refurbished refinance hmo in
liverpool i'm here with my wife amanda
here's a thing i need to get amanda's
input because
we're in the interior stage now
hello how's it going
yes yes yes how are you doing we've got
all the lights on
not really enough uh nice all the
switches are on
kitchen's all up and running uh
we just had the final one called we're
going to move the sockets upstairs
and moving so that's where they are in
yet but they'll be in tomorrow this
looks nice though doesn't it now it's
all plastered
yes nice smoke alarms going up tomorrow
so yeah really great good
really just a bit of initial one of the
showers plus i forgot to put the cable
through
so if i scored him for the cable but i
found it the plastering looks like it's
dried out nicely
yeah yeah it's quite recent when was
this done now here
uh this was done last friday was it
earlier
last week last friday cool one day last
week
so this is the kitchen amanda we won't
disturb you by the way we'll
we'll walk around and film so so
basically the kitchen's good isn't it
it does look really good it does look
really good yeah i also
think that i love the the worktop
that's quite nice yeah i'm so glad that
we chose
to knock down the bathroom at the back
of the house yeah because now it's given
a really
spacious big kitchen it would have been
terrible wouldn't it yeah plastering
looks like it's pretty much finished
now so this is basically the stage where
we're up to now
where i kind of lose interest because
once the actual you know i mean the main
work is done now
it's pretty much just final fixes now
isn't it
yeah final fixes um the and then
obviously the interior
stuff so decorating carpets going down
but although that's that's where i lose
interest that's not the case if you use
it amanda no that's where i get really
interested
so you get interested so let me show you
around this is the front room
cool so you can tell me what you think
it looks good it's still quite a good
sized
bedroom isn't it it's a really good
sized bedroom i love how big this
ensuite is now it's
quite a good sized room still with this
in here
yeah and then the shower is quite big
you can see the shower tray
the old swigs oh it's like a decent
sized
yeah you know yeah the home sweeps are
big
yeah that's nice we're gonna put the
toilets in last because if we put the
toilets in too early
yeah then all these guys will um [ __ ] in
them
you what it doesn't look like it's far
off finished now doesn't it no it
doesn't
it doesn't just needs a really good tidy
up too a good tidy up decorating
yeah doors are obviously going to go on
like last so when the electricians first
come in
which are these guys what what's the
difference between the first fix and the
second fix
first fix is when you put all the cables
in yeah second piece is when you put all
the guns on the white goods or
whatever you're wrapping on it yeah you
know for everything
uh upstairs all the cables are already
in the loft just ready to be talked
through
they didn't get pulled through for the
reason that we didn't know where the
shovel killed
was going at first
cable manual fuels board everything
brand new great
so this dude chris has just come in he's
responsible for fitting all the skirting
boards
which uh look like they're pretty much
finished yeah they are
so 99 are you gonna be doing the doors
and stuff at the end as well
possibly yeah possibly hopefully if you
do a good job with the skirt is there
definitely
[Music]
definitely wearing the wrong shoes i'm
wearing my always shoes
i wear these for everything they cost me
a fortune
and i'm going to be wearing them out
okay
so yeah from this room look how big the
windows are
really really nice
i like it upstairs definitely looks more
finished doesn't it
i guess that says message yeah yeah
really good skirting ball to put in
which is great
what kind of light you did say the
light's going to be pulled through
didn't he
yeah it's a big ensuing
it is big once this is painted
that is gonna look so nice oh yeah once
it's painted
i'm thinking carpets maybe like a gray
yeah
you can't go wrong and then with the
walls maybe white and potentially just
put some feature balls in
yeah definitely
all right come on through
and then this is the third room
nice oh this is like the best room isn't
it
yeah you'd want this room yeah
also as well they did put this
um they did this wall
ended here okay but i wanted a bath so i
made them move it back
so that we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna have
a bath along here a nice bath
that's good um with a shower in it nice
and then you've got a toilet sink lots
of space
yeah yeah it's the nicest drew in this
one isn't it
what's that this one's the nicest room
yeah this is a big room
[Music]
so just the final touches now with the
with the with the joiners
you need to probably get another skip
soon the amount of times we need to get
skips
it's crazy yeah
the kitchen's come out knife hasn't it
yeah
the only thing that will be honest is uh
it's just kickballs because the floor's
gonna go in yet
yeah so that's all i think cool we're
gonna get
laminate flooring on
so amanda you were quite involved in
choosing the kitchen the design of the
kitchen
yeah yeah really nice you're happy with
it yeah
yeah what do you think of the what are
they doing in the door
just plastic it's very clean isn't it it
is well you don't have
there's no handles yeah yeah so you can
just literally which is nice
and it's soft clothing too it's okay
they're gonna be
getting changed or they just stay like
that and then should we paint it
whenever they're painting i don't know
are they gonna get tuned yeah
so in conclusion we're almost done now
almost done
plastering's finished kitchen's going in
skirting board's going down now
now it's the time for the last phase
um should be finished in the next two
weeks to reckon two weeks
two weeks maximum this place will be
done which is when we're then gonna get
the revaluation
and then once we've got the revaluation
we're gonna get the tenants in
and i'll do a final video real soon show
you exactly
what is what
it's a really big house key safe as well
so the workers can let themselves in let
myself out
i can't wait to get rid of this this is
i tried to get this down
but it just wasn't happening i think i
needed to get the guys to do it but um
better or worse than you thought it's
better than i thought
it looks like it's quite near completion
are you thinking how to take that down
oh no just the scrolls
oh yeah you make it sound easy i tried
for five ten minutes made a right fall
on myself
everybody was coming out here a minute
i'll show you while you're sucking
oh really all right go on here we go
this should bring it down what i was
thinking is if you do all the work
and unscrew it and then i'll take the
glory and pull it off
[Music]
[Applause]
that was easy wasn't it
[Music]
you